we are back with Billy Ray Cyrus fire
Rose and Sam J give it up
everybody so last season we announced
that our partner pilot pen was searching
for their next $100,000 G2 overachievers
grant winner that is not typo that is
100 Grand y'all there are some people
out there who go above and beyond to
make our world a better place just
walking around here just being angels
and that certainly describes my next
guest her organization helps children
and Foster Care find Forever families
that's why pilot select Ed her as a G2
overachievers finalist and shared her
story with us which we are so excited
about please everybody Welcome Marcy BAC
along with Pilot's vice president of
marketing Arian
langson so meet everybody
hello and and Marcy I'm going to start
with you so explain to everybody
forgotten adoption option kind of rolls
off the top right it really does it's
very nice yeah explain how it works yeah
so essentially I coach families through
the adoption process so many people are
really familiar with you can can spend
hundred thousands of dollars tens of
thousands to adopt a child and it takes
a long process or you can become a
foster parent and maybe you'll adopt
that child but maybe maybe not yeah
people often don't know there's a third
option and that's why it's called the
Forgotten adoption option there are 30%
of the children currently in foster care
are adoptable right now and you can
adopt them and in fact that process is
shorter the financial investment is at
maximum $2,500 the state often covers
health insurance to Children until
they're 18 so that's Oran they're
forgotten sometimes they're overlooked
right overed I had never heard of this
before you I had you heard of this
before I'd never heard of it yeah so
what stood out about so many great
organizations come across you know your
disc so like what stood out about
Marcy's well what really stood out about
Marcy is that she is an incredible
overachiever she um fits with the g2
Paradigm that write more do more achieve
more and I'm not sure if you know this
but Marcy is a professional she is a
technical analyst she also recently
finished her MBA she has been a pageant
contestant and winner she's written okay
I know just all those look at all those
bullet but but there's more okay so let
me keep going so she has written two
books a third one is coming out very
soon she is a podcaster she is a wife
she and her husband adopted two children
from Foster Care yeah and in her Spare
Time Marcy has helped over 12,000
families through the process
how do you have spare time and all of
that I'm like what where is the spare
time if I write a fourth book it might
be on time management I I was yeah I
need that book desperately um so this
work is very personal to you right yeah
yeah Kelly when I was in my early 20s I
had the opportunity to go on a service
uh project over to an orphanage in
Europe and I spent a good portion of my
week with teen girls yeah who were in
this orphanage and it really hurt like I
just felt the burden in my heart of man
these kids they're growing up without a
family and they're not just growing up
in their childhood like they're growing
up with their lifetime without a family
and when I came back to the US I thought
I'm not okay with what I saw and I need
to do something about it and so I
decided I'm going to adopt as my plan a
and that's what my husband and I did we
actually adopted two kids together
they're biological siblings yeah oh
that's great cuz it's good to keep the
siblings together yeah yeah there's
significant need there are a lot of
siblings whether it's two or kids that's
a big need in the Foster ha space and so
I started blogging about our experience
through it kind of is a complicated
difficult process and that's what ledged
the organization that I founded today
it's a very beautiful thing well um
Arian you have something to tell Marcy
right yes um so Marcy we fully support
what you're doing and your mission and
um you really have made the impossible
possible for so many children and you
know just like the G2 pen longest
writing stoppable you are unstoppable so
we want to offer you all the g2 pens and
writing instruments that you need for
yourself and all the families that you
are working with through the adoption
process oh my incredible
go well actually there is one more thing
I wanted to tell you and that is you are
not just a finalist for the G2
overachievers Grant you are in fact the
G2 over Achievers grant
winner that's
$100,000
so well here is some good news Marc is
today's $100,000 G2 overachiever winner
but you can be next pilot pin is once
again looking for adults and students
who go above and beyond to make their
communities and the whole world better
for us all that is why Pilot's hosting
the $100,000 G2 overachievers Grant and
the $15,000 G2 overachiever student
grant they both go to outstanding
overachievers who go all out to improve
the lives of others submissions for the
20203 G2 overachievers grants are open
right now so don't wait too long y'all
all submissions are due by De December
15th find out how to apply at
g2overachievers tocom stay right here
everybody I'll tell you what I'm liking
[Music]
[Applause]
next thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home